you might think that v80 is just a
boring fact of life but v80 adds an
enormous 1 trillion euros to the
revenues of EU governments every year
that's equal to 7 percent of the EU s
GDP in fact it's one of the biggest
success stories of our single market but
our vit rules need modernizing so that
we can more effectively tackle
cross-border fraud so that all EU
countries add the tools they need to
collect the revenues that are due almost
170 billion euros in v80 revenue was
lost in 2013 which means half a billion
a day 50 billion of that was due to
cross border fraud it's obvious that
this cannot continue
that's why it is crucial that we put in
place a simpler more modern and more
robust EU ID system with today's action
plan the European Commission is
proposing innovative ideas to make life
easier for small businesses especially
those that trade online we're looking at
measures to fight cross-border v80 fraud
and launching a debate on how to bring
VT rates more into line with the current
piece of our economies we need v80 rules
that are clear and data fraud proof
I believe that today's action plan on
vit can deliver on each of these issues